wang juste - avants avant qu'il dénonce
le scandale est ce que ça vous a un
petit peu saoulé la polémique avec avec
laurent baffie ou pas c'est tomber un
mauvais moment passé ça en ce moment
c'est mémé c'est ça m'a saoulé pour pour
lui parce que si c'est bien une personne
dans le paf qui est pas comme ça qui est
pas misogyne et un vrai et qu'il ya où
les filles vraiment c'est laurent baffie
et vous comprenez que certaines filles
qui a été choquée parce qu'ils l'humain
ben voilà sur et qui vivent des choses
difficiles au tour le tour donc voila
mais absolument c'est un combat à mener
pas besoin que jamais aujourd'hui et
mais c'est vrai que bon là d'ailleurs je
le précisais sur le sur les jurés tôt
c'était ça faisait partie son sketch je
trouve que vous avez été une fois de
plus parfaitement dans vos réponses
nolwenn et je voulais encore vous
remercier
[Applaudissements]